one of the commonalities one of the
patterns that you spot really quickly if
you interview hundreds of world-class
performers and i just interviewed 130 or
so for my new book tribal mentors
is the fact that they have consistent
morning routines they have some type of
recipe a boot up sequence that they use
to win the day in some fashion
and it ranges from for instance
mindfulness and that could be
mindfulness meditation
where you find say evan williams who is
well known for blogger twitter also
medium
who spends time every morning as i do
with some type of meditative practice
could be
insight it could be a transcendental
meditation you could use an app like
headspace which i think is a great place
to start and it trains you it allows you
to practice becoming more aware and less
reactive so that you're not thrown off
by the unexpected challenges and
problems of the day and that helps you
to be much more productive and much more
centered
you can achieve that in other ways
gratitude is a common element so tim
o'reilly who's just an incredible
entrepreneur thinker writer
and
thought leader in silicon valley goes
for a run and will take a photograph of
a single flower on his run every morning
right and this teaches you to pause
to pause and to assess how you're say
responding to things so that is a really
beautiful practice that can be done with
gratitude lists i use something called
the five-minute journal but whitney
cummings incredible stand-up comedian
writer and much more also has gratitude
lists
and this is say naming three things that
you're grateful for each morning tony
robbins does this brian grazer
incredibly well-known
iconic tv and film producer also does
this i think he's had 180 emmy
nominations or something like that
and that achieves very much the same
thing of present state awareness and
looking for the positive as opposed to
fixating on the negative
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn some of
the morning habits of successful people
enjoy
habit number two exercise read and plan
with brendan burchard i get up i
immediately drink 20 full ounces of
water i refill that thing and i'm going
to drink that next 20 ounces of water in
the next you know half hour easily
what i do
after that first like just get up drink
some water is i immediately hit the
floor and i do anywhere between 10 and
20 minutes of mobility work on my body
or yoga or calisthenics stretching
basically i'm just opening up my body
i'm just stretching out and being very
mindful of my breath for 10 or 20
minutes as i'm moving on the floor doing
some vinyasa flows and yoga to open up
my body open up my radiant just get
awoken up to my to my body
then
i spend 20 minutes
reading
and for me i read either spiritual texts
psychology texts self-improvement texts
or philosophy texts those are the main
things i read in terms of books right
it's almost always spirituality
philosophy psychology or some type of
self-help self-improvement for 20
minutes minimum i just sit and i read
then i get up and for 20 minutes i then
plan with my high performance planner
which i know most of you guys have or i
hope you do the high performance planner
because the reason i do that for 20
minutes is because there's all these 10
prompts
in the morning section to help me
anticipate my day and create a strong
mindset create sort of a a healthy way
to look at the day i ask my question
myself questions if you don't have that
performance planner i ask questions like
one thing i can get excited about today
is if one word would describe the person
i need to be today it would be this
somebody who needs me today to show up a
situation that might stress me out or
trip me up could be this situation today
and the way i'll deal with it is this
way
somebody i could surprise with a note of
appreciation a gift gratitude something
beautiful i'll talk about one action i
could do today to to demonstrate some
excellence i'll talk about you know a
bold action i could take and i'll think
about the big projects i have in mind
then i'll fill out my goals
i'll figure out the tasks that must
happen today
i'll detail the people i need to reach
out to this day
and then i'll look at whatever i need to
do that day or i'll maybe have my
planner or my calendar for my phone or
my computer and i'll write it down i'll
always write it down and i'll look at
what are the major tasks and activities
through the hours of the day and then
what i do people are like that takes you
20 minutes i'm like no honestly filling
out my planner might take five to seven
minutes the morning but then what i do
is i look at each of those things
and i ask myself how can i do that thing
with excellence
like today i knew i was going to film
this for you and i said okay right
before i'm going to make sure i move my
body i'm going to get my mind ready i'm
going to be alert and really serve
with gratitude
and with fire for people when most
people just want to be play kid i'm
gonna challenge people and what i do is
i visualize the whole day every meeting
every conversation just walk it through
what would make that successful and
excellent and be a value and i just
think about that so it's like a
visualization basically for 20 minutes
i'm planning the day i'm visualizing day
those are huge habit number three start
with an intention with marissa peer
starting your day right set you up and i
start my day with an intention
i say good things to myself i'm happy i
love my life then i have another
intention i do good things to myself i
eat well i hydrate well making smoothies
puts a lot of hydration into my body
i'm also a great believer that people
who succeed do what they do not want to
do first you think oh i don't want that
i do it later i do everything that's
important first i make my smoothie
i drink it i get set up for the death
and when you wait i do that later i'll
work out later i'll take my vitamins
later it doesn't work do it first
if every successful person does what
they don't want to do first
and you do it too you're joining a very
successful group
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four have a clear
schedule with lewis howes i love to have
a clear schedule of the week
exactly what i'm going to do what is
everything going to do to support me
emotionally physically spiritually
financially relationally what am i going
to schedule in and i also schedule in
leisure time okay
i'm going to schedule these four hours
i'm going to do nothing or i'll do
whatever i want or i'll just hang out
with friends i schedule it in that way
i'm just not distracted by my phone
or whatever is happening in the world
i really try to eliminate
the negative distractions from my life
the best that i can
and in no way am i perfect but it's
something i try to focus on by having a
clear schedule so when i know where i
need to be
and i know what i need to show up and
how i'm supposed to show up
it it allows me to stay focused and it's
going to be clearer and clearer towards
my mission and my vision for life that's
why it's important to go back and write
down what is a one sentence your mission
or your vision for this season of your
life
who are you who do you want to be what
do you want to create what do you want
to accomplish and why if you can get
clarity on that in one sentence then
you'll create a schedule that supports
that mission and vision for you and your
life
so have a schedule if you don't know
what you're creating on a daily basis
you're going to be responding and
reacting to what life gives you as
opposed to you creating what you want in
life
it also sets you up for lower stress
levels
and it can really lower your stress
levels because you're accomplishing
so many positive moments
or tasks
for for yourself the first thing in the
morning and you don't have to worry or
think about doing them later so if
you're like okay i know i want to get in
shape i know i want to eat well i know i
want to drink lots of water today i know
i want to meditate i know i want to
breathe at some time and you wait until
after
you're exhausted
you try to wait till six o'clock seven
o'clock at night when you come home from
whatever you're doing at work or
whatever you're doing school you're
gonna be tired it's gonna be really
challenging to have focus and energy
this is why for me it's really important
to
learn the skill of spanish i want to
become fluent in spanish one day that's
one of my goals
and i was taking spanish class in the
beginning the first six months
around six o'clock at night
and this was after a full day of work
this was after an intense workout and my
brain was fried and i couldn't
stay awake
i'd be in an hour session and i'd be
like over zoom after i'd done zoom calls
all day and i'd be like this trying to
remember stuff and after months i was
just like i can't do this at night so
what i did is i started scheduling it at
8am
and it's one of the first things i do 8
a.m
i work on something that is meaningful
for me something i want to learn a skill
that takes and requires a lot of my
mental energy and by doing that first
thing in the morning it sets the tone
for the rest of the day i feel more
confident i feel like more productive
and i'm doing something i care about
first thing
and it lowers your stress so you can
improve in other areas as well so again
it's setting the tone it's lowering your
stress levels because you're not waiting
to the end of the day you're not like i
got to do this thing later that that
energy that stress
will will hurt you in every other area
of your life
so you want to take care of your body
you want to take care of your mind in
the morning and it allows you to show up
to love those things around you instead
of
taking out your emotions on people and
experiences in your life habit number
five plan the night before with brian
tracy you can increase your levels of
optimism each day
by planning every day in advance
the ideal time to plan is the night
before make a list of everything you
have to do in the coming day and then go
over the list and use the abcde method
to set your priorities
it's amazing how much better you sleep
and how much more positively you will
awake when have already pre-planned your
day when you know exactly what you're
going to do and in what order
so starting today begin applying these
beneficial morning rituals to help
increase your productivity and tackle
anything the day has planned for you
habit number six control the first and
last 30 minutes of your day with ed
mylett i had a hard time staying
disciplined in my days like so many
people do
my mind and my actions and so i have
this philosophy that if i can control
the first 30 minutes of my day
and the last 30 minutes of my day the
probability at least of having some
measure of control over the rest of it
is increased and so the first 30 minutes
of every day i get up and have a very uh
routine process i go through but one of
the processes both in the beginning of
the day and the end is i ask myself a
series of questions what am i most
grateful for in my life right now
because the quality of the question
changes the quality of your life and
your thinking what am i most grateful
for who am i most grateful for who loves
me who do i love what am i most proud of
right now what am i most looking forward
to in my life and i do that at the
beginning of my day at the end of my day
what did i accomplish today what did i
learn today what am i grateful for who
do i love who loves me
and those questions they may seem hokey
but i've been doing them for 25 years
almost now and they control what i see
in my life because there's a part of
your brain called the reticular
activating system and this is the part
of your brain that kind of filters out
anything that's not important to you and
filters in what is important to you it's
almost like the matrix so for example
we've all experienced this if you ever
bought a new car like a
you know a blue
lexus or a blue honda
all of a sudden you see blue hondas
everywhere don't you they're in the
parking lot there are three lanes over
on the other side of the road also you
see them everywhere why they were always
there but now they're filtered into your
awareness and you see them everywhere we
all know what that's like well what if
the blue hondas of your life were what
you're grateful for what you're proud of
what you're excited about what you're
achieving and by asking these questions
they become important to your reticular
activating system and believe it or not
you begin to see
feel and hear things that were always
there that you would miss before just
like that blue bond it's a powerful
thing we do with our minds inhabit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is apply the
90-91 rule with robin sharma for the
next 90 days spend the first 90 minutes
of your work day on your single most
important opportunity to move the needle
in your industry and i'll repeat that
again with great respect because it's so
important i believe to your productivity
the 1991 rule is simply for the next 90
days
spend the first 90 minutes of your work
day on your single most game changing
opportunity because what happens a lot
of us get to work and we spend our best
hours on our least important activities
we get to work and we start checking our
social feed we get to work and we check
our text we get to work and we chit chat
at the water cooler about the latest tv
show that we watched last night
and research has shown that the morning
hours are when you have the most focus
when you have the most energy and when
you have the most willpower
and so you want to use that first 90
minutes you know that is that is game
time that's show time
start preparing the night before
most people have great morning routines
they start the night before when you
actually have a little bit more time so
instead of trying to cram everything in
to that
hectic ridiculously crazy morning
help make it easier for yourself by
planning a little bit more the night
before so if you're one of your goals is
to exercise and to run more the night
before set out your shoes set up your
exercise gear set up your clothes so
that all you have to do is wake up and
put them on if one of your goals is to
eat healthier and you're tired of going
out and eating mcdonald's for lunch or
whatever it is then the night before
plan your lunch make a sandwich make a
salad
create something healthy have some
snacks you can just go to the fridge
pull out your bag and you're off to work
today's my video day
when i know what it's my video day the
night before i set up my camera i set up
my gear set up my microphone it's all
ready for me to go so all i have to do
is walk in and press record and i'm
ready to go make it easy for yourself
don't cram more into your morning
prepare the night before why is the
morning routine so important couple
things
how you wake up
has a scientifically proven impact on
your ability to focus
on your
happiness
and on your productivity all day the two
to three pieces of it are for me
i wake up when the alarm goes off i then
get up and for the first couple minutes
of the day i plan my day and i have a
particular process that i go through
that leverages something from harvard
business school called the progress
principle i have a mindfulness practice
that could be anything that you want it
could be gratitude journaling it could
be meditation it could be five slow deep
breaths it could be taking your your dog
outside for a walk and then on mornings
when i can i have a micro exercise
practice where i do planks for five
minutes or i do something to get my
blood pumping on the mornings that i can
i and i do all that before i ever even
look at my phone because i put myself
and my mindset first deliberately before
i ever allow the world access to my mind
you do not want anybody to have access
to what's going on up here until you've
gotten deliberate about what you're
thinking about first the first 60
minutes or so are
very clearly defined and that's the
recipe i use to set up the rest of the
day step number one i wake up
and i meditate for 20 minutes typically
22 minutes it's 20 minutes of seated
transcendental meditation it could be
vipassana it could be head space and
then two minute decompression period
where i sit there and let my mind do
whatever it wants to do i get up
brew tea very frequently oolong tea or
some combination of say
turmeric ginger and pour that's another
favorite then i sit down to journal and
there are two different types of
journaling that i do depending on the
day
for different purposes one would be
morning pages where i'm effectively
vomiting my brain onto the page
to trap my monkey mind in print so that
it doesn't bother me for the rest of the
day the other type of journaling i do
is best encapsulated in a journal called
the five-minute journal there are
different ways to do this but i'm
writing down three or four bullets
of items people relationships anything
that i'm grateful for
which is a very very very nice
way to set the rest of the day so that
you're
viewing life through a lens of
positivity then there are a few
questions related or prompts i should
say related to focal points for the day
ideally immediately after that i'm
having a small amount to eat and then i
would go into exercise of some type that
exercise could be
riding on a on a peloton bike and doing
a 20 minute hit workout high intensity
interval training or it could be acro
yoga or could be
weight training or working on a concept
2 rower
and that would be
generally no more than 60 to 90 minutes
in length sometimes it's as short as 20
minutes
and then shower off to the day first of
all your morning routine starts the
night before so go to bed early but i
try to go to bed as close to nine as
humanly possible every night save for
the weekends
and in that
i sleep without an alarm so i wake up
when i wake up the reason that i do that
is because i want to get as much sleep
as i need so i'm all about cognitive
optimization so
i'm not somebody who sets the alarm to
make sure that i'm up at four in the
morning but when i wake up at four in
the morning i'm a very happy camper um i
usually get it used to be between five
and six i'm now getting between seven
and eight i have no idea why it changed
completely randomly and as far as i can
tell without reason uh but i wake up
when i wake up i give myself 10 minutes
to get out of bed and i do that because
i'm lazy and my inclination is to lay in
bed so i need a bright line that says i
get out of bed immediately without
wasting time so i'm out of bed and out
of bed in 10 minutes or less i put my
gym clothes next to my bed so that the
easiest answer is to put my gym clothes
on in fact i'd have to make a conscious
choice not to which thusly would trigger
in me a lot of
conflict emotionally because it is my
identity to immediately go to the gym to
work out again
partly for cognitive optimization and
then also for longevity uh for health
and for aesthetics
but working out i think is incredibly
important and i actually think that for
anybody that wants to achieve something
extraordinary in their life that
the third thing that you need to focus
on is mindset the first two are diet and
exercise
followed by mindset so i hit the gym
first and foremost immediately after the
gym i meditate and the reason that i do
that is because i want to practice going
from the sympathetic nervous system
which is fight or flight which you're
triggering in the gym through the heavy
exertion your heart rate is up your
breathing is shallow and rapid and the
idea is to very quickly switch over into
the parasympathetic nervous system where
you're getting into
rest and digest where you're calming all
of that down you're slowing your breath
your diaphragm breathing
into the nose out through the mouth and
really calming everything down and i
think practicing that transition is very
important when i wake up in the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself usually in
bed what am i most grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful
for to be alive i'm grateful you know
for my family i'm grateful to to have
experiences and do you do you do that
eyes closed yeah i do that eyes closed
and while i
while i think about that i feel it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
i start every day with a great feeling
you have do you visualize some things
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue um i see images of
the things that i'm thinking about and
that just takes me two minutes just two
minutes when i wake up
and then i go to exercise to take care
of my body how long um usually one hour
to an hour and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise
in my gym
around
half an hour an hour 15 minutes at the
moment
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my
you are known for that yes so i have my
vision board for my my physique and my
body and my health
but then i also have in my gym something
called an achieved board
okay so after i achieved some of the
things that i achieved best in the
future no achieved in the past yes so
past you have the past and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
uh like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus
to achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals what i
also do is i reinforce most people focus
on what's not working this isn't going
well this didn't work i want to remind
myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror
in the gym and i look across and i say i
love you just the way you are and i said
i accept you just the way you are with
all of your skills and passion and
faults and insecurities and doubts and
fears i accept you just the way you are
and i smile
and then i close my eyes and i do about
a 15-minute meditation wow
and
in my meditation sometimes i have
um no thoughts where i'm just one with
the universe and everything other times
i'll just follow my thoughts and i'll
just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain
that i'm in control of my brain don't
press news
snooze doesn't help by the way snooze is
one of those things that just simply
doesn't dream killer yeah it's like it's
news
that's the answer yeah it's like a
complete i think it's gonna help you
dream more but it's not it's gonna
destroy your dreams it's a whole
psychological trick
if you press news the thing that you
think expressing the snooze helps you
with like just get that extra eight
minutes of sleep that eight minutes the
sleep doesn't give you any more energy
by the way 18 seconds
there's there's an 18 second window
in the morning when your alarm goes off
that sucks it's about 18 seconds so 18
like the alarm goes off and you touch it
yeah the next 18 seconds are like a hard
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds
then you're okay you just get get away
from the pillow it's pulling you in like
yeah some tractor feed
you need to get away from that problem
so that 18 seconds and once you're up
and you're moving you're good walk me
through a day in the life what's it look
like right now well i mean it's got to
be crazy
right now i i leave here and i fly to
oregon
and i'll be in oregon with uh cameron
haynes we'll be getting out there for a
few days
a lot more podcasts a lot more
interviews but every day
every morning i get up i still get my
run in every morning
how do you structure the training the
training is basically structured off of
my schedule so look at my schedule
and i said okay um jennifer what do we
have today
we have this at seven o'clock in the
morning roger that that means i gotta be
up by four o'clock in the morning to run
that's how it works
that's how all my [ __ ] works so she lays
out the schedule of events two hours you
just you just set it two hours earlier
she says it could take an hour to get to
rich rolls let's say we were at seven
o'clock today in the morning it takes an
hour to get to rich rolls with no
traffic okay let's block in the hour 15
for rich roll okay we got that the
morning time i'm gonna run seven miles
this morning
i need uh 52 30 for that
roger that put in
[ __ ] shower shave add that in
so the schedule dictates but
i have always just push it back right so
that means getting up at 1 30.
trust me roger that i've done that
several times yeah
several how much sleep do you usually
get
i i like getting seven to eight hours of
sleep nowadays i can do that but there's
times where the schedule says hey man
you're getting three hours and if that's
the case
right merry christmas usually before the
sun comes up
i
offer myself
to something greater than myself
[Music]
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes i at least stop in that space in
my house every morning
i have a little meditation space where i
just go i have beautiful spiritual
readings there
i light my three candles there
daily word or something and i express
to this greater energy field than i
that
i don't want to be alone as i move out
into the world i teach people
that daily you have to prime yourself
you have to do something for 10 minutes
minimum if you don't have 10 minutes you
don't have a life
and ooh that's so good i mean i just
like you've got to do it right that's
good if you don't have 10 minutes you
don't have life to give to priming
yourself that's right
prime life you want a beautiful life a
beautiful family i'm so i'm so i i i
love that you're what i do the first
time i wake up in the morning
people always ask me how do you sew up
all the time but yeah probably as i
attend all these seminars you know i
teach all this but the real reason is
you prime yourself i primed myself
that's what i've done for years it's
like i've changed my body with this
radical breathing pattern or movement
there's many ways to do it but then i do
through 10 minutes and i do it usually
goes more because i'm enjoying it yeah
but 10 minutes is how i get myself to do
it
three and a half minutes of pure
gratitude about three things
and i take one of those three to be
simple because i don't want to be the
astronaut that you know he went to the
moon that was his idea adventure and
then they all come back and we're
depressed because what do i do for the
rest of my life yes so the wind of my
face you know my children's faces um
anything and the reason for gratitude is
the two emotions that mess us up the
most are fear and anger yeah and you
can't be grateful and fearful
simultaneously they don't go together
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously so if you literally start
your day cultivating that this part is
talking about creating a highway to
happiness yeah and then i do three
minutes of my three to thrive what are
three outcomes and results i'm really
committed to and i see them as done and
fulfilled and in time for that day
i usually look at something at six
months to 12 months out something a
little bigger and then
what i feel is fulfilled and done i give
thanks for it
and you're at the end of those 10
minutes and usually it's 15 or 18 for me
i am so wired now i've done that for
years it's been the base of me
what's different with suffering
is measuring it moment to moment oprah
and then the third one for me is okay
how do i love more because love to me is
an action it's not a word it's not an
emotion it's like if you love you act
accordingly so love and what can i do in
a loving way and that what can i be
grateful for and that little three-step
process
ends the suffering you must come up with
a morning routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself
and in control of your day
this is what i do
and i cannot explain the power that i
get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost
wake up on time when that alarm goes off
get your butt out of bed five four three
two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why is because the first
decision that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses
you are persistently bigger than feeling
lazy
and you are persistently beating the
feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email before you
answer your phone before you start
surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed and
you know team stream and checking out
the sales on zappos and looking at your
facebook news feed before you pick up
the damn phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day these are the things that matter to
you whether it's saving money and and
making sure you're focused on that or
showing up at work and being a
contributor or whether it's changing how
you treat your spouse or your kids or
the person that you're with or heck
getting to the gym because you said you
would whatever it is that your two
priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day
is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or their friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got some
money you start off your day looking at
that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking ass every
single day do you think you do so well
in business because you're dedicated to
looking after your body and leading an
active lifestyle
100 i think if you can find an hour or
two a day for yourself
uh for your body then you're going to be
able to do
you know five or six more hours of
creativity throughout the day and and we
all know you know when we let ourselves
go
you know we're we're just not going to
perform as well so
you know one of the reasons we set up
health clubs
in pretty well every you know all the
major cities around the world is
um you know is it is a passion of mine i
think it's so important that people you
know
keep healthy what's your morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so i get up i
do that four days out of the week i go
to the gym and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was the
killer part of the book every
night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover
recovery is big the mind especially the
mind and the body this is my time
there's no phone calls there's no emails
the world does not exist
because i have to get ready for tomorrow
get the body open up why because as i
won't get you know two years you went
deep into it
but your body's getting tight yeah
you go hard tom a lot of people go hard
what happens is that stress yep starts
to tighten up that psoas muscle hip
flexors so lower back you got back
problems all of a sudden you have no
idea why it's all tightness it's all
tightness man because you're constantly
charged and going hard morning i wake up
have my caffeine walk in the morning
four o'clock in the morning but by the
way that's the magic hour that four
o'clock in the morning is when no one
else is up so no one else is bothering
you and you can focus on whatever work
you have to get done i'm sending these
electronic mails those things right i've
heard of them yeah those things and then
by 4 30 4 45 i'm doing some sort of
cardio so in this case i come out here
open these garage doors
it's still dark outside so it's just me
and a whole bunch of blair witch things
that are happening out there in the
woods
and i jump on this thing i do this and
then i'll have breakfast and then i will
go do all my strength and conditioning
training at a gym for about an hour and
then i'll go to set so total workout
time for all the dudes that are like i
could look like that at home right now
how much run time cardio and strength do
you do a day
between cardio
strength and resistance training
stretching maybe about an hour and 45
minutes okay that's not too bad not too
bad too bad it's not all in one shot
okay you have to be watching your diet
because we know diet like they say abs
are made in the kitchen so more than
you're working out diets everything i
can tell you right now is just to find
balance as well okay so it's a little
bit of everything yeah sure so i think
carbs are your friend when you find
yourself under stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments
things don't work out as you hoped you
must feel
a moment of anxiety a moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can
go out of the stress
i can at any moment like there are times
when i i feel the stress of the
circumstances
and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
and just
see things
in a different way and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me feel more
centered and in control but like tennis
players they say at the height of their
game
the ball seems to go much slower the
whole game slows down yeah and it's
really
that equanimity
that produces that kind of a reaction as
distinct from
when you have the anxiety
there's not the clarity there's it's all
coming too fast i always try to hire
people that are smarter than me and that
complement my skills skill sets like i'm
a ready fire aim guy and i always try to
partner with people that are very anal
and perfectionist to kind of balance me
out or have a skill set that i don't
have um but once i'm going i mean i
would go to events and like this and
listen and learn and go to conferences
and when i get the opportunity i'll ask
questions but i'm not i i can't ever say
ever what i've said
i'm going to call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm going to have
to be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business and
it's it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming and i've
always had the attitude that whatever it
is so if it's virtual reality if it's
the oculus rift it's new to everybody
except the people who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else and then it's just a question of
effort of learning it as well as
everybody else so other than going to
the originator of the idea concept
product service whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and and
having the opportunity to learn it so
i'll just put in the time to learn it so
from a tech perspective and that that's
always served me well because once you
understand these different products you
understand how they fit together and it
also helps you make decisions and
understand what will work and what won't
work certainly uh being focused on
something that you're confident will
have high value to someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment um because people are
attend tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking um so a challenge for
entrepreneurs is to say well what's the
difference between really believing in
your ideals and sticking sticking to
them
versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things right now so you need to be sort
of very rigorous um in your self
self analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and
um
and then just work like hell i mean you
just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour
weeks every week
and then a lot of work that all those
things improve the odds of success okay
um
i mean if if if other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in 100 hour work weeks then even if
uh you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve you will achieve
in
four months what it takes them a year to
achieve you guys are just getting
started
you're not gonna start right here
you're gonna start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning i'm gonna beat that sun
up every morning so that i had the
discipline and the control of over my
life
so i knew hey before that thing pops
i'm gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i had the same
weekends or for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was gonna do
that i woke up when i said i would wake
up and i start building respect for
myself start believing in myself so that
i can go out into the world and maybe
maybe maybe today
maybe today when i go into this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money if you practice
any new skill for 66 days in a row
through the power of neuroplasticity
which is the brain's ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5 a.m than
to stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this morning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery
rhyme or learning how to read or
learning how to build relationships at
first there's not a lot of facility and
fluency with those skills because every
skill is difficult at first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place where you master it and so
your morning routine is going to be
challenging at first but with daily
training and practicing the 20 20 20
formula i promise you you're going to
get to a point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold i
mean the balance of work and play is
critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now so
critical to
find time for yourself get out there and
keep fit and and i find the best way of
keeping fit is by playing
[Music]
i try to
encourage our chief executives worldwide
to make sure that there's as much
flexibility in in the workplace as
possible
we've set up something called the b team
which is examining the way companies
treat their staff and trying to make
suggestions to make the dignity work
better than it's been in the past
[Music]
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office you get bogged
down with the manuta uh if you can step
away from the situation
uh you can think about the bigger
picture and um that's what i am able to
do
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
necker with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to extract carbon out of
the earth's atmosphere you know sitting
in muhammad looking up at the stars at
night things like virgin galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work so um a
great way of capping off the day watch
the super bowl with a cup of tea and
a chair
anyone that you want to let's say uh uh
go against anybody you don't like
anybody that's as pleased as you anybody
you want revenge for anybody that you
hate anything you remember that someone
did bad to you
let it go
forgive them
you don't have to say it out loud you
can say to yourself i forgive you people
you really really hate it's amazing what
happens amazing
something lifts off your shoulder
and the negative isn't as strong as it
was before this is an amazing thing that
cost absolutely nothing i cannot change
yesterday's newspaper i'm not gonna let
it burn me down because by being in my
subconscious mind everything around me
looks bleaker because i had this bad
stuff
happen to me before that i want a
revenge or that i hate it's still in
that subconscious mind get it out of
there get it out there by saying i
forgive you no matter how bad they work
i forgive you no matter how much revenge
you want i forgive you no matter how
just it is or injustice i forgive you it
lifts the burden off you so when these
little things start happening and
they're little things now but they're
actually gigantic to you now in the
future you would have gone through it it
would have been smaller but one way to
make it smaller now is get off your
shoulder out of your mind all that
disrespect all that hate all that
revenge all that jealousy get them out
of there forgive everybody for just
forgive them
and you'd be amazed within 24 hours
maybe for one hour something is just
lifted off your shoulders this is one
good direction to start going into and
it doesn't hurt anything to meditate and
if you don't know how to meditate just
sit there close your eyes sit upright
close your eyes put your hands wherever
you want and just uh close your eyes and
just look at a white light in front of
you if there isn't one in front of you
mock one up if different things enter
your mind the thought that could enter
your mind is i am i am part of god i am
and then you can focus on something and
if you can do that for 20 minutes in the
morning and 20 minutes at late afternoon
or at night you'll be amazed at how
freer your body is every morning what do
you reach for
uh well i read
new york times wall street journal the
economist is sort of my regular weekly
fair um
he can give you
last week's by memory he knows every
word
that's great it's great to have
something you read on a regular basis
and they do special sections um
charlie what do you read well i agree
with bill i think the best one
publication i read is the economist
which is interesting yeah well i read
that but i i read the local paper
i read the ft i read the wall street
journal i read the new york times and i
and i read usa today i sold fax machines
door-to-door for seven years after
graduating from college
and i
you know
for 20 years spanx is going to be 20 i
started it in the year 2000 and um
the sound bite in the media has been
sarah cut the feet out of pantyhose and
solved an undergarment issue and you
know now spanx is here and and while
that is true there was so much more
about the behind the scenes of why this
happened and people have asked me can i
have 10 minutes 15 minutes of your time
i want to pick your brain on how spanx
started but the real answer is it
started way before i cut the feet out of
my pantyhose and it it it started when i
was much younger and
i had a series of kind of tragic events
happen to me when i was in high school
and it led me to wayne dyer who is a
motivational inspirational speaker he
passed away about two years ago but i
got exposed to him and i listened to his
cassette tapes over and over and over
again to the point that i had his one
series called how to be a no limit
person
memorized all 10 cassette tapes front
and back
and try living with that
well yeah that's funny because in high
school no one wanted to get stuck in my
car like after a party they're like
she's going to make you listen to this
and so um but then you know i said i
said i think i would take simple things
like i'm just gonna do the laundry
tomorrow and she'd be like do you know
the ramifications of waiting till
tomorrow
so um but then fast forward you know i
think it was 10 to 15 years after high
school that i ended up on the cover of
forbes and the texts i got in my phone
were so funny i mean literally all my
friends were like damn shoulda listened
to that
so but i'm a big believer in it i
learned early on about manifesting law
of attraction not caring what other
people think about you which is a really
big one for an entrepreneur or you know
in life really and i'm a work in
progress on that there are times where i
do care and i check myself and say you
know let's let's work on this but it's
very freeing to not care what other
people think you'll take more risks
um to not really focus on the outcome
and be so afraid to fail so all of that
is a big part of my journey and and
spanx
[Music]
oh it's cold this morning
you can beat that freaking thing up
get up before it is
gives you a sense of
i'm winning man i hadn't even done
anything all i did was get out of bed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so dr you know i dressed for success man
i got to grab my favorite watch here
[Music]
spend probably 15 or 20 minutes a day
just responding beat the sun up see that
that encourages him
and he encourages me
and it just works it works we all we all
help each other
[Music]
bubbles
[Music]
listen to the birds huh
i hope you're gonna have a great day
today because i am
i have a great day if it's a bad day i'm
gonna turn it into a great day
because that's what i do
some of the days that have started off
bad for me have been the best days of my
life
you just got to hang in there you got to
stay in there
you got to keep pushing and shoving say
dude i'm going to make a bad day a great
i'm going to flip this thing i'm going
to turn it on its head it's just a day
just today let me turn this thing you
turn enough bad days into great days
you'll end up with a great life
that's it man nobody they don't teach
that in school if we're not fit and
healthy we're not gonna be able to
achieve anything so
um you know so you know i will swim
around the island uh every day or i'll
you know go kite surfing or i'll play
tennis or i'll you know i'll do
something to make sure that the body is
healthy and
the endorphins are running uh and
um and and then i can throw myself into
work um
and i suspect
um at least 50 of my time is sort of
setting up not-for-profit uh
organizations in the world to tackle you
know some of some of the bigger problems
of the world um and
you know the other 50 i suspect is
diving in and out on you know some of
our businesses around the world you know
maybe doing a bit of firefighting when
things are going wrong
or
um you know giving them a push you know
when things are going right i wanted to
give you some specific insights on the
value of rising before the sun and
joining the 5 am club which is a concept
i've been teaching to my billionaire
clients and ceo clients and
executives at companies like starbucks
and fedex and ibm and nike and other
organizations that i've worked with for
over the past two decades with
tremendous success in terms of helping
them increase their focus their energy
their productivity and their performance
so
there's a reason why
the visionary founder of starbucks
howard schultz
rises before the sun there's a reason
why michelle obama rises very early
there's a reason why tim cook who's
leading apple
gets up before the dawn first of all the
hours between four and six are the time
of least distraction in this age of
dramatic interruption
number two
the hours before the sun rises
is the period where your brain is most
available to your primary creativity so
while you're sleeping your brain
actually washes itself but also it lets
it go the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available
to access
your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why i
encourage you to get a brill you might
say robin well i'm not an early riser i
can't put mine over mattress i can't win
the battle of the bed grandma never got
up early dad couldn't get up early i
guess i'm not the kind of person who can
rise before the sun and what i would
suggest to you is simply this
what science confirms in particular the
data of university college london you do
any new habit practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not to
66 days
of rising at 5 00 a.m will get you to a
place where it's easier to get up to 5
am then not to get up at 5am you'll
reach a place of automaticity
in my book the 5am club i say all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle and it's gorgeous at the end what
is your strategy for dealing with
distractions
that's a great question
yes
something that
is that you've heard about
you've heard about this but it's that
thing like are you willing to go to
where you need to go and get out your
comfort zone
the number one thing that has been able
to help me with
distractions is two things
one of them is prayer
just taking two minutes
to quiet everything out and talk to god
and then the second thing which i was
like i can't do this like
i can't even believe i said that
it's meditation
meditation
if
if that's one thing you'll take away
which
which
from today is just go on youtube and say
10 minute meditation
smooth music some type in anything 10
minute meditation i gotta go see my girl
she mad at me you know what i'm saying
like whatever it is
type it in
and
and just just really kind of clear your
mind i have four children under the age
of eight he turned to eight last week so
um time alone is even more sacred and
it's a time that i absolutely need to
carve out for myself so one of the
things that i did is i found out when my
best thinking time is and it's in the
car so i live only five or six minutes
from the spanx headquarters but i
actually many times leave my house an
hour before i need to be at work and go
on a fake commute
so my friends have laughed and called it
my fake commute but i realized that's
when my mind wanders and
and that's when my ideas come to me and
so i have to carve that timeout so i'm
driving around with all the other
commuters and i'm like the happy
commuter because i and i don't ever have
an agenda of where i'm going sometimes
i'm in inman park sometimes i end up in
downtown sometimes i'm in decatur i just
drive around and there must be something
for me about the activity of driving and
being able to think and just listen to
some background music that accesses a
certain part of my brain and i read the
other day that einstein had all his best
ideas when he was shaving and so there
must be something about a rote activity
that you're doing that allows you to at
least at least for me it's driving so
that's one thing that i would say that i
do so find out and identify when your
best think time is and and make sure
you're you're making that happen in your
life and i'm not talking about when
you're just going through your checklist
of everything you have to do i'm talking
about when does your mind wander
and if you don't have enough time carved
out in your life for your mind to wander
you're not accessing
the best part of yourself
because there's there's a knowing inside
of you and it's when you're when you're
in that space not when you're watching
tv and not you know it's even more
difficult now with how much distractions
we have from ourselves i'm going to
share a little trick with you and all
viewers
you see these pencils here on my desk
i've got these all over the place
i got probably thousands of these
and i have
this this is the lowest tech thing
you've ever seen sticky note
during the day here's one i just this
morning
i write down things i have to get done
i know it's slow tech there's all kinds
of software can do this for you i don't
care
i like pulling a pencil
and simply writing down oh yeah i got to
get that thing done and just making that
note
i learned this from a very successful
person years and years ago my mother
and
this note
just sits here all day and at night if i
haven't finished and usually there's
three or four i haven't done i look at
it and say
okay
tomorrow
i will get this done
before anything else before you know i i
go online before i read anything you
know i go watch television before i make
any phone calls or texts or anything
i'm going to get this thing done and i
stick it on the mirror on the right hand
side
number one
record baseline for track 15. all right
so i found a piece of music that i
recorded back in 89 i'm working on a
documentary about
watch dials which i think you're going
to find interesting when i finally get
to finish but it needs the music so the
editors can work with the beat of the
music
and this thing i recorded in 89 does not
have any bass and i didn't play bass
back then now i do so i'm going to go
back in the studio and lay down the bass
track for track 15.
[Music]
number two
reconcile foreign currency i have
investments um over in europe and uh
each month i reconcile to the currency
to figure out how much of the
performance was gained or lost by the
change in the currency rates so i want
to do that this morning it's important
to get that done for last month because
you know
if you don't have that information you
can't make moves and
number three
tape questions four and five for tax
hive tax hive is a new business i've got
involved in as an investor and also as a
spokesperson
this is a company that helps small
business with their taxes and payrolls
very important in my portfolio companies
so i'm recording some messages
and four and five have to be done today
so i'm gonna go in the studio and record
those great take that's the one before i
do anything else today these three
puppies are gonna get done
and that is how you get super productive
and you don't let anything distract you
you don't take a phone call you don't do
emails you don't do anything you get the
things done that you made the priorities
the night before do it every day try it
it's fantastic look at this low tech
low tech you write it down a piece of
paper stick it on the mirror come on it
works in different places
in life i promise you
you're going to find
you don't know where to go
everybody goes through this the most
successful people in the world wake up
some mornings
with no clue
what to do today
okay so first thing i want you to know
is that it's normal it happens to
everybody it's not like you're a bad
person or you're lost or you're
depressed or
you got some problem you need to take
medication for everybody everybody
regardless their stature in life where
they are regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint
promise you no matter how much they
present
like they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody everybody
has those days
and the sun is kicking today has those
days
where uh
they don't know what to do
i don't know what to do
you know uncertainty show up even when i
don't want to okay and then what i try
to do is i try to help one person
one person
[Music]
and what happened over the period of 34
years i did that every day i'm not
depressed anymore at least not for long
periods of time i don't use any kind of
medication don't use any kind of drugs
don't smoke weed don't drink over
excessively drink i might have a drink
once in a while
and
got a beautiful wife two beautiful kids
and for the most part my life is
freaking wonderful all i did was this i
don't over analyze
never do i label myself a loser a
quitter
um
i'm hard on myself i never i never label
myself
ocd acd add
ocdd whatever a depressant uh alcohol
like a drug addict no no i don't this is
what i do i do things okay show up
move in the direction i don't
overanalyze moving the direction that
that i think could be
more pro-survival than staying in one
place and number three
helps somebody there's a lot of emerging
science saying here's the reality and
anyone who wants to dismiss it is
denying science which is
planet earth is a tiny planet in a
galaxy of trillions of planets
um my friend deepak chopra was on my
stage
at one of my events a few months ago
he's a lovely man he just radiates
goodness
and um he took us on a tour de force
about cosmology and he's been a pioneer
for so many years and he confirmed the
science which is we are all part of an
energy source whatever you want to call
it god uh nature life and you're
absolutely right jay your intentions are
creative so we could come at it from a
cosmo cosmological point of view when
you say here's who i want to be you know
this morning in my journaling i'm going
to meet jay
i'm so delighted and blessed that he's
invited me on his show because he
influences so many people how may i
serve
that intention
hopefully is creative so we're very
powerful
i'll come at it another way which is
epigenetics
epigenetics as you know
stands for the emerging field of science
which is you are not your genome the old
school said your dna what you get from
mom and dad that's your destiny we're
now realizing that epigenetics means
our environment our daily rituals like
getting up at 5 a.m our thoughts
what we eat our peer group etc
literally affects the up regulation or
down regulation of our genome
what does that mean it means
if you believe in yourself if you do the
work in the journaling if you get up at
5 00 a.m and do that victory hour and go
through the 20 20 20 formula you
literally are recalibrating who you will
become out in the world so you're
absolutely right then you start
channeling your intentions
and you start stepping into your power
like we are awesomely powerful beings
most of us have blocked our our intimacy
with our true power what i want to talk
to you about today is a note which i
call daily
so if you create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily
and then write the word do
colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
call in
the one thing i would ask you to do
walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note
check it throughout the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so what you put in
each one of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts is to
notice something that you never want to
do it again you never want to do again
and you just add that to it
very very simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back
to this moment number two for me is be
vulnerable
show people my mistakes
show people my fears
because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three
drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
this goes with one of my don't which is
don't drink hard liquor or beer on
weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups
throughout the day i just have to do
them every day
six sets of 30-second planks
run for three miles
meditate on this list
stand up straight
which whenever i say i always see
posture moving in the audience
say hello to everyone i just bought a
heavy bag so i'm training with a heavy
bag so i want to spend 10 minutes with a
heavy bag every day
i want to do a video journal
every single day and i want to get seven
hours of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of them
well my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them
don't eat sugar
i'm on the paleo diet so don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the weekdays
um so this list while it sounds very
very simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check throughout the
day and i check right before i go to bed
and i make sure that i check everything
off
and go through it i've given it
to our companies um i've given it to a
number of students that i've talked to
as we've gone to schools and recruiting
and people have come back to me and said
that this is something that works for me
it's something that's easy to do and
something easy to remember
one of the most fundamental things about
it that i've learned that i've taken
away from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
uh everything else that's going on all
the other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so this do and
don't list for people and individuals in
the company has translated to a do and
don't list for our company
for square we have a do and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no too for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast to continue to innovate and to
really push the boundaries and continue
an event and question
and and reset everything that we think
about the organization if you think
about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference whoa that's
good okay go ahead so visualization is
simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
einstein brain the imagination
we now have just activated one of the
biggest centers of our brain the
occipital lobe that's connected to the
motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational circuit the nucleus comes
that releases that dopamine that makes
you feel good that makes you want to
take action so if you
you're
visualize
achieving the goal if you visualize
yourself behaving in ways that match the
new belief if you even visualize the
words or you take the words on a sheet
of paper
and you read them run your right finger
across it run your left finger across it
close your eyes see it and feel it your
brain is creating a mental movie with
the words and as it creates a mental
movie with the words that's happening in
your subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety and then number
three is energy conservation now when
you do something 20 30 40 50 times it
takes about 66 days to
365 days of repetition to override an
old habitual circuit not 10 days not 21
days 66 to 365. so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal feeling the
success that you want to feel
seeing the belief on the screen of your
mind you are actually creating a neural
network through the science of
neuroplasticity and the networks that
you reinforce become the most dominant
networks and since your brain wants to
conserve energy
if you do this on a consistent basis
your brain says okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs and now you've deliberately
and consciously evolved yourself here's
your new definition of passion
passion is simply
energy
that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay
and why don't you in the comments tell
me where are you watching from and tell
me about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate
about what you were doing
about where you were about the people
that you are with describe that moment
for me because when you start to
really investigate
passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you're super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walkathon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm um doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever i am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion
now i'm being very deliberate in how i'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
going to make me
passionate what job is my passion what
is my purpose on the earth i'm going to
tell you what your purpose on earth is
right now your purpose on earth is to
figure out how to align your life so
that you feel more energized and excited
by it that's it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm you're not going to
think your way to passion you can't
think your way to finding something that
you feel in your heart it doesn't work
that way you gotta feel your way into it
it's inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here and so what you
have to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're going to find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you and so here's the
thing
so for
those of you that have been watching
coffee talk for a while or you've read
the five-second rule book or maybe used
the five-second journal or maybe you
took mindset reset with us this january
you've probably heard me talk about the
fact that inside of you there is power
you have an inner compass
and that inner compass is always guiding
you and learning how to read that inner
compass is essential if you want to
unlock the passion that's already
naturally inside you
passion again isn't a person place or
thing that you're gonna find it is a
state of being that you unlock inside of
yourself and it is there and you can tap
into it right now
so there is an inner compass inside of
you that i call an energy gauge it's an
energy gauge that reads the energy in
you and around you and that energy gauge
goes from moments when you feel depleted
dead and empty to moments where on the
other side of the gauge you feel
energized alive expanded and so the
truth is
your natural state believe it or not
is to be
on the energized expanded side of the
internal compass that's in you and so
you are never really lost i'm telling
you this i know you may feel lost i know
you may feel defeated i know you may
feel depleted i know you may feel stuck
these are all temporary states
and one of the fastest ways for you to
start to change how you feel about where
you are in your life is to tune inward
and to start to read the energy because
if you feel stuck your natural energy is
depleted if you feel despair your
natural energy is depleted and the
fastest way to start to shift that is to
shift the energy inside you and to start
to align your life towards things that
energize you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know what millionaires do as
part of their morning routines check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there most people
are literally beginning their day
checking their text their voice message
and their inbox which is all other
people's agendas and needs from you
so again you are starting your day